FEMALE SPEAKER:
Thank you to everyone
for joining us here today and
sharing your lunch time with us
to welcome Cara Alter.
I know that many of
you have read this.
And this is why
you're here today.
So I want to share a little bit
about what you haven't read,
and how we were fortunate
enough to meet Cara and bring
her back to Google, because
she's been here consulting
for us in the past.
I was at the professional
businesswomen's conference
with several of
our women leaders.
And as we went back to
the table at lunchtime,
everyone had the same feedback.
Did you go to that talk,
that Cara Alter talk?
Oh my god, that
totally blew me away.
And we encouraged
other folks to go.
And then we were
fortunate enough
to speak to her after
the talk, and convince
her to come back to Google and
share her message with many
of us.
So a little bit more
about Cara-- she's
provided training
on public speaking
and managing nervousness
to some of the world's
best known companies, including
Alliance, Caterpillar eBay,
Gap, Google Ideas
and Williams-Sonoma.
And what we really
loved about her talk
was how approachable
her methods were,
and how it was
really easy for us
to take a lot of what she
shared to the forefront right
after the talk.
So thank you, Cara, for
joining us here today.
[APPLAUSE]
CARA HALE ALTER:
Hello, everyone.
Great.
This conversation
is going to look
like a conversation
about public speaking,
because it's pretty formalized,
in that I'm standing up here
at the front of
the room, and you
are sitting in audience mode.
But this is really about
the image that you project.
And that can be one on one,
or around the conference room
table, or standing up
to give a presentation.
But this is about inspiring
confidence in your abilities.
There are some people,
just in the way
that they carry
themselves, you immediately
have faith that they
can get the job done,
whatever the job might be.
And some people do it with a
big, bold, dynamic personality.
And some people do it with
a very calm, down-to-earth
demeanor.
But whatever the style,
you just believe in them.
The fallacy is that those
kinds of positive assessments
that we make about
other people--
that they're all very
subjective, that they're
based on nuanced or
indefinable criteria.
And I've spent the last 20
years of my life researching
how human beings assess
other human beings.
And the bottom line is that
there are ground rules.
There are metrics.
Certain behaviors lead to
very predictable assessments
on the part of the listener.
So you can better
understand what behaviors
lead to what assessments.
You can just be more in charge
of the image that's coming
across on the other side.
Are you aware that
certain facial expressions
are hardwired into us?
Not all facial expressions, but
certain core facial expressions
like fear, joy, anger, grief.
And it's why we can read facial
expressions across cultures,
or why babies can read facial
expressions a very early age.
Well, the same thing is true
for your body language signals.
A significant portion of
your body language signals
are what we call universal--
how human beings assess
other human beings.
And so I'll give you
an example of one--
keeping your head level.
So literally being
level-headed is
a show of confidence across
the globe, wherever you go.
Now whether you should show
confidence is a value system.
And sometimes that changes
from culture to culture.
Sometimes, in some
cultures, being deferential
is a far better
way to do business.
But being level-headed is a show
of confidence wherever you go.
If I raise my chin
just a bit, this
is a very high-status
position to be in.
And if I continue to speak
to you with my chin just
a little bit high, you
are very likely to find
me a little condescending,
a little arrogant.
Can you see that?
If I lower my chin just a
bit, this is a very low status
position to be in.
And if I continue to speak
to you with my chin low,
you're very likely to find me
a little shy or differential,
and especially if
I tilt my head.
Now whether or not
I personally am
aware of the
position of my chin--
because I could be oblivious
to what's happening up here--
it is still having an
impact on your side.
And even your side,
you're not consciously
aware of what behavior is
sending the message, because it
just happened so fast in there.
So if I had started today
with my chin up like this,
and said, hello,
everybody, I'm very
excited to have this
opportunity to talk with you,
you would all begin to
make an assessment of me
really quickly.
And your exact adjective
would be up to you,
but you would all be leaning
in the same direction.
But it is doubtful
that any of you
would have identified
that it was
my chin that was bothering you.
I mean, you wouldn't
leave afterwards and say,
you know, Cara was OK, but
her chin-- it was so high.
You would just be stuck
with your assessment of me.
So that's why it's
my job as the speaker
to be very aware of the
signals that I'm sending out,
because they're having an impact
whether I am aware of them
or not.
And have you heard
studies about how long
it takes for someone to come
up with an assessment of you?
AUDIENCE: Under 30 seconds.
CARA HALE ALTER:
Under 30 seconds,
seconds, right, so seconds.
I recently read the
research from Nalini Ambady.
She was highlighted in the book
"Blank" by Malcolm Gladwell.
But she is the researcher who
coined the term "thin-slicing",
which is our ability to see
a pattern in just a very thin
slice of information.
In one of her
research projects, she
showed people videotapes
of individual strangers.
She had them assign
adjectives that they
would use to describe
the person on the screen.
And at first, she showed the
videotapes for two minutes.
But then she just cut
it back and cut it back.
And she got down to two seconds.
And she found that
the adjectives people
would use to describe the
stranger on the screen
were the same whether
they had the opportunity
to see the videotape for two
minutes or for two seconds.
That's pretty amazing.
Actually, it's
amazing on two levels.
First of all, it's amazing
that it happens so quickly.
But more importantly for
today's conversation,
it's amazing that there's
general agreement.
When we watch a
videotape of a stranger,
we will all use about
the same adjectives
to describe that person.
So if that is true, there
have got to be ground rules.
And so that's really
what the credibility
code is all about-- what
are the ground rules?
What are these behaviors?
How much impact do they have?
How much control do
you have over them?
I had the pleasure to
have worked with Google
over the last few years.
So I know a good deal
about your culture.
And in a workshop, early
on in the workshop,
one of the things that
comes up is a conversation
about authenticity.
Because there's a high value
here on being authentic.
And I want to knowledge
that and support it.
I want you to know,
I believe that you
are going to be at your best
if you're first yourself.
And that it is really great if
you have some strong speaking
skills on your side.
So I want you to think
about the ground rules
that I'm about to lay out,
like the rules of punctuation
or grammar.
As a writer, we don't feel
inauthentic in our writing
because we're following
the rules of punctuation
and grammar.
And you wouldn't say,
as a writer, well,
we're all following
the exact same rules.
How will my unique
voice come through?
So the truth is, if
you aren't following
the rules of
punctuation or grammar,
people aren't likely to
pay attention to you.
And there are some
really talented people
who can break the rules.
So let's acknowledge that, too.
And just makes it
more interesting--
I give you permission
to break the rules, too.
But break the rule because
you know the power of it
and you choose to do it
differently, as opposed to just
being oblivious as to how that
behavior might come across.
All right, I've broken
the conversation up
into three sections-- first,
what I call the basics.
And these are those
behaviors that you
need to do just to get those
basic level adjectives,
where someone might
describe you as comfortable,
competent, capable, credible.
Of course, you want
that as your baseline.
And then we'll talk about
those things you shouldn't do.
I call those derailers--
so those behaviors that are
almost always invisible to us.
We don't know that
they're going on,
but they nonetheless
undercut our image.
And then I'll talk about
the perfect balance
between being authoritative
on the one side
to being approachable
on the other.
And the best
communicators of all
know how to do both
at the same time.
And just to give
you a quick preview,
I will show you what it's like
to lean too heavily in one
direction or the other.
If you're using a lot of
authoritative behaviors,
and I just kicked into a
few more of them right now,
you're very likely to come
across as capable, competent,
an expert.
But if you rely too
heavily on these behaviors,
you could also come across
as unreceptive or inflexible,
which isn't going
to help you create
a relationship with the
person on the other side.
On the other end
of the spectrum,
if you're using a lot of
approachable behaviors--
and I just kicked into a few
more of those right now-- well,
you're very likely to come
across as interactive,
personable, maybe even dynamic.
But if you rely too
heavily on these behaviors,
you could also come
across as a light-weight--
nice, but inconsequential.
So you need to have a
balance between both sides.
And if you personally
know that you
need to bolster one end of
the spectrum or the other,
I will give very
specific behaviors that
tend to send those messages.
OK, going back up to the top,
the very first thing someone
notices about you is
the visual picture.
So your body language
has a big impact
on your appearance of
credibility and confidence.
The three pillars that hold up
your appearance of leadership
presence, of credibility,
of personal presence,
are strong posture, strong
voice, strong eye contact.
If you're doing
those three things,
you are going to look good--
strong posture, strong voice,
and strong eye contact.
Now most people have heard some
version of this advice before.
It's not like it's a brand
new concept out there.
But most people severely
underestimate just how
important those behaviors are.
So let me be explicit.
Strong posture means that
if you're standing up,
your weight is balanced
equally over both feet.
And whether you're
seated or standing,
your spine and your shoulders
form a T, like a metal T bar.
And this area right
here is rock solid,
has literal core strength.
So notice how if I allow
myself to have just a little
more wishy-washiness
in my spine,
I lose a lot of my
executive presence.
So you have literal core
strength through here.
Then your head and shoulders
move independently.
So your head moves like a
camera on a tripod, which
means I can look over here,
and I can look over here,
and I can look over here.
What's not happening is this.
Again, I'm back to
wishy-washy or being
a little kid in trouble.
And think about how eagles and
owls survey their surroundings.
We call them regal and wise.
And then one more--
your nose has
to point directly toward the
person you're speaking to.
So if I'm looking
at you, my nose
points directly towards you.
And if I look at you, my
nose points directly to you.
Notice what happens
when my eyes move
a little more
independently of my nose.
I'm very likely to
look uncomfortable.
But I could also look sneaky,
or mischievous, or judgmental,
or skeptical.
Have you heard the phrase,
looking out the corner
of your eye at someone?
What does that mean?
Reticent, questioning.
So if you want to come
across as straightforward,
you have to literally be
straight on with the person
you are speaking to.
There's a concept
in communication
that is called marked and
unmarked communication.
And ultimately, what we're
trying to do with our body
language signals is
unmark the communication,
so that the power of our
words will take precedent.
Sometimes we're sending
some accidental signal
that sends a mixed message.
And so let me give you an
example of how this played out
recently.
I was working with a
group of teenagers--
actually a group of young
mothers in a job placement
program.
And one of the young
women said to me,
parents and teachers say
that I show attitude.
And I don't get what they mean
by that, because I really don't
feel like I show attitude.
But she said it to me like this.
Parents and teachers say
that I show attitude,
and I don't get-- you need
to straighten that out.
So if I look at
you this way, this
is unmarked, straightforward
communication--
me just talking to you.
And as soon as I start
to move my chin around,
it marks the communication.
So if you want to unmark the
communication so people will
really hear what
you have to say,
you need to be literally
straight on, direct.
So here's the takeaway in
this particular section--
if you want someone
to describe you
as having a strong
spine and a level head,
you need to literally have a
strong spine and a level head.
And if you want
someone to describe
you as straightforward
and direct,
you have to literally be
straightforward and direct.
It is pretty amazing
how the language we use
is a literal translation of the
attribute we are describing.
So standing with your weight
balanced over both feet,
how might you describe me?
Grounded, balanced, on solid
footing, upright, strong spine,
firm backbone, level-headed,
head square on my shoulders,
standing on my own two feet,
not easily pushed over.
There are so many positive
metaphors here-- fully evolved.
So you want to make
sure-- oh, and let's
take some negative metaphors--
being a slouch, or shifty,
or unbalanced, or crooked.
So you want to physically
embody the metaphors
you want people to use
when describing you.
All right, now if you just
learned in this conversation
that you should
stand stock still,
well, that would
be a problem, too.
Because part of
leadership presence
of looking perfectly
comfortable is fluidity,
owning the space around you.
So your core provides the
solidity and your hands
and your facial gestures
provide the fluidity,
the interactivity.
Hand gestures are hard
wired into all of us.
They're are a form
of communication
that's deeper and older
than verbal communication.
And even blind people
gesture when they speak.
It's not something
we learn visually.
It's hardwired.
But what is most interesting
about hand gestures is
that they are an unconscious
communication process, which
means when you are
not thinking about it,
your hands are very much
engaged in the conversation.
And as soon as you become
self-conscious-- as soon
as you begin to think
about the hands--
you have no idea what to
do with these appendages
at the end of your arms.
And when that
happens, we tend to go
into some sort of lock-down
mode, or I call it masking,
masked mode.
And it's that apparent
self-consciousness
that gives away the fact
that you are intimidated
or nervous by the situation.
When we are perfectly
comfortable,
our hands talk when we talk.
If you want to exhibit
executive presence,
personal presence,
the second your mouth
begins moving your body
language has to talk, too.
Because what intimidation looks
like is your mouth is moving,
but no other body language
signal is online yet.
You don't have to learn
how to hand gesture.
You gesture hundreds
upon hundreds of times
throughout the day.
It's not a skill
you need to learn.
What you need to
learn is not to mask,
not to allow yourself to go
into these lock-down positions
when you are, in
fact, intimidated
or nervous by the situation.
And the way to counteract that
is to reach out, literally.
Another literal metaphor-- reach
out, hand them information.
And by the way, this gesture
where I reach out and hand you
information, is the
most common hand gesture
we use when we are talking--
hands reaching out.
And you can do it when
you welcome people.
I could say, hello, everybody.
Thank you very much
for being here.
I'm excited to have
this chance to talk
to you about this project.
So you can do it as a welcome.
But you can also do it when
delivering facts and figures.
I could say, the towers
of the Golden Gate Bridge
are 746 feet above
the water line.
So it doesn't matter what
you're talking about.
Hand them the information.
Since hand gesturing
is unconscious,
you might have to get
over a learning curve
where thinking about reaching
out is a little weird at first.
You have to do it enough
times that your brain stops
having a conversation about it.
And usually that happens about
20 times practicing anything.
So everybody do this
for me for a second.
Close, put your hands
like this, and just know
what thumb is on top.
And now switch.
Yeah, feel a little weird?
Exactly, but there's nothing
more natural than this or this.
It's just one is
habitual and one is not.
Now if every single day
for about 20 seconds
for the next 20 days, you
did this-- the other thumb
on top-- by that time
you might begin to think,
which one did I like better?
I've forgotten.
So if you just keep
doing the behavior,
pretty soon your
brain doesn't have
to have a conversation about it,
doesn't feel unnatural anymore.
And that would be true about
opening up your body language
signals on purpose.
But let's practice.
I know we have some people
in remote audiences.
So I want you to practice, too.
I want everybody to stand up.
Stand with your weight balanced
equally over both feet.
And where your feet should
be depends on your gender.
This is not a societal issue.
This is about balance point,
because for women, our center
of gravity tends
to be-- not always,
but tends to be-- in our hips.
So the most balanced
place for your feet
would be directly
underneath those hip joints,
directly underneath
those joints.
And for men, because
your center of gravity
tends to be in your shoulders,
the most balanced place
for your feet would be directly
underneath your shoulder
joints, which is a
little wide for me.
And I don't know if
you can see my feet,
but this is another example
of marked and unmarked
communication.
This is not a natural
position for my feet.
So if I stood like
this, it would
look like I'm trying to tell
you something with my body
language-- a little
extra message coming on.
So this is the much more
natural position for my feet.
And for men, the same
thing would happen.
If you stand with your feet
a little too close together,
it marks it in the other
direction, certainly
but it will look a
little unnatural.
So just so you know, in all of
my research about body language
signals, I filter for, what
does natural look like?
So basically, we could
do it on purpose,
even if we're not feeling
natural or comfortable.
I am firmly in the school of
"fake it till you make it."
But one reason that's
true is that when
you begin to embody
these skills,
you really do you begin to feel
internal authentic confidence.
So I support that.
All right, so you're standing
with your weight balanced
over both feet.
Hands by your sides.
Most people feel a little
uncomfortable with their hands
by their sides, but this
is a natural position,
believe it or not.
So make sure your head can move
independently on your head,
like a camera on a tripod.
Now some people tell me
that they feel stiff.
Are you feeling a little stiff?
So let me show you
what stiff looks like.
[LAUGHTER]
So your head and your shoulders
moving together-- that's
what stiff looks like.
And your head
moving independently
on your shoulders-- that's
what loose looks like.
And if you were
sitting on a park bench
somewhere, looking
around, your head
would be moving independently.
You wouldn't be turning
as you looked around.
All right, so now
pick up your arms
like you're holding the biggest
ball you could possibly hold,
but your fingers are
touching-- huge ball
but your fingers are touching.
Where your fingers
are touching, put that
in front of your belly button.
Draw that circle in you mind.
Really see that circle in your
mind, and then drop your arms.
This is your personal space.
So now show me with
your hands this way
that you are perfectly
comfortable moving
in this bubble of
space in front of you.
If you reach past this
space, OK, that's weird.
[LAUGHTER]
But this space belongs to you.
This is your personal territory.
And try to avoid the
T Rex version of this.
[LAUGHTER]
That's not it, either.
OK, so you want to
prove that you're
perfectly comfortable
whether you're seated
or standing, the second
you're mouth begins moving,
allow your body
language to say, hey,
I'm comfortable here in
this space in front of me.
You may now have a seat.
All right, so there we
have strong posture.
And when I say posture, I
really mean posture gesture.
They go together like two
sides of the same coin.
They really have
to happen together.
But now strong voice--
there's a big difference
between being technically
understandable
and really reaching people.
And I want to hit this
point pretty hard,
because this is where
most people have
an opportunity for growth.
In a workshop, if I can
have the opportunity
to give someone
individualized feedback,
I use a metric from
1 to 5, that goes
from just being OK to
truly being exceptional,
to evaluate that skill.
So for volume, let me give
you my scale from 1 to 5
so you can hear what
this might sound like.
One on a scale with
volume-- well, 1,
you wouldn't be able to hear me.
So I'm actually not going
to demonstrate that.
But you get the idea--
1, couldn't hear me.
2 is a bit like
this, which means
you have to work pretty
hard at hearing me.
Now you can hear me.
Actually, the microphone's
not helping, but there we go.
You can hear me.
It's just that you're
doing all the work.
So this is Level
2, below average.
Level 3's about like this.
Level 3 is average.
And most people, by the way,
speak at average volume.
It's OK.
It's adequate.
And if you like being
described as adequate, it's OK.
Level 4 is hopefully where
I've been speaking all along.
Now with this volume, I'm
coming all the way to you.
I don't expect you to do the
work in this communication.
So 4 means optimal
for that situation.
It's always a sliding scale.
It depends on the
size of the room,
the acoustics, the background
noise, the situation itself.
Level 5 is that one step too
far, where if, at Level 4,
I was really making a
connection with you, at Level 5
you begin to put up boundaries.
It's a really big drop from 4,
getting the perfect connection,
to 5, getting you the
opposite of what you want.
People put up barriers.
Most people
intuitively know this--
that if you come on too strong,
people will put up barriers.
So they gravitate to the
safety of the average zone.
And that is the
most common mistake
I see anywhere I go-- people
who are willing to be average.
Most people would
consider it an insult
to be described as average,
and yet that's the safety zone.
Unless you have gotten
feedback in the past
that you really are too loud
at work on a regular basis--
it doesn't count at home.
Because the thing is, the
more comfortable we are,
the louder we get.
So it doesn't count
if you get feedback
at home that you're too loud.
But if you get feedback on
a regular basis that you're
too loud at work, or
too much, or too big,
or something along that line,
OK, pay attention to that.
But if that does not come
your way on a regular basis,
you have room to expand.
You can just bump it up a notch
and you will be more effective.
The payoff is huge.
The stronger your volume,
the more confident,
the more comfortable, the more
authoritative you come across.
For articulation-- and that's
the clarity with which you
pronounce your consonants--
the more clearly you enunciate,
the more intelligent
you come across,
the more attentive to details.
So for example, if I'm
using this especially clean
articulation, it's going
to be very hard for you
not to get the impression
that I'm attentive to details.
Because my articulation
is attentive to details.
But if I'm using the type
of articulation right
this very second, I know you
can understand what I'm saying,
but I doubt that I
sound as intelligent
as I did just a second ago.
So it's not about being
technically understood.
It's helping them to get
the right impression of you.
And the more clearly you
enunciate, the more intelligent
you will sound.
For pacing-- that is your
words per minute-- in general,
the more slowly you speak,
the more comfortable, the more
confident, and the
more authoritative.
And this makes sense.
If I'm speaking
slowly, I indicate
that I have the authority
to take up your time.
But also, we tend to associate
nervousness and pace.
And so if you just
speak quickly,
purely as a matter
of habit, you are
likely to come across as less
comfortable because of it.
Expression-- the
more expression you
bring to the conversation,
the more personable,
the more dynamic, the more
engaging you will come across.
And then the last one
on my list is resonance.
Resonance is your vocal quality.
It's the tone, the timbre,
the texture of your voice.
And on this pie chart
that is your vocal image,
it takes up the most
space-- takes up
a lot of space on that list.
So let me bump up the
level of resonance
in my voice at
the moment, so you
know what I'm talking about.
Right now, when I'm
speaking to you,
there's a lot more
rumble to my voice
than there was a moment ago.
Now if I began this conversation
with this level of resonance
in my voice, you would
be thinking to yourself--
why is she talking like that?
Because I get it.
It's too much.
But you get the idea
of what resonance is.
I can do a lot of things wrong.
But if I have
resonance in my voice,
I'm going to sound like a
force to be reckoned with.
So for example, if I'm using
this level of resonance
in my voice, but I'm giving
you some classic signals
that I'm very uncomfortable
up here, because I'm
crossing my legs, and
playing with my fingernails,
and darting my eyes.
Even though my body
language signals
are screaming that
I'm uncomfortable,
my voice is compensating
heavily in the other direction.
And so would be hard to
get the impression I lacked
a certain personal power.
But this can work
against you as well.
I can give you lots
of physical signals
that I'm in charge-- balanced
weight, fluid gestures,
direct eye contact.
But if I pull back
on my speaking voice,
and now I have this little,
teeny speaking voice,
even though my body language
signals are nice and strong,
I'm not going to look like I
have a lot of personal power.
The quality of your voice
says such a strong platform
for how seriously someone's
going to take you.
And the quick fix
for bringing out
more resonance, more texture
to your voice-- speak up.
Speak at optimal volume.
That is the easiest
way to get there.
Now, the deeper dive--
the technical thing
that's happening-- is you need
to get your diaphragm engaged.
So right now, my diaphragm
is working overtime.
And right now, my diaphragm's
not working at all.
So that is the technical
thing that's happening.
So let's do a couple
of exercises for that,
so you can experience what
it's like to engage this area.
To shortcut, I'm calling
this the diaphragm.
But please recognize
there are lots
of muscles working in concert.
You have the diaphragm.
You have the abdominal muscles,
the intercostal muscles.
But I'm just going to
shortcut, say diaphragm.
We want to get this engaged.
So in order to feel this area
engage, I want all of you
to say "shh" really loud.
Here we go.
Shh.
No, twice as loud.
Here we go.
Shh.
Great, so did you feel
this tuck under there?
I could see it happening,
so that's great.
Excellent, so that's your
diaphragm being engaged.
If you know anything
about exercise physiology,
you know that to build
any muscle group,
you have to put it under
a little bit of strain
and then it'll get stronger.
So we're going to put this area
under a little bit of strain.
I want you to say the days of
the week all in one breath.
And I want you to elongate the
vowels so that you can't take
a rest in between each sound.
It's not going to sound normal.
It might sound something
like this-- Monday, Tuesday.
So that's what we're going
to do-- days of the week, all
in one breath, nice and loud.
Here we go.
Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
Thursday, Friday, Saturday,
Sunday.
Now you really should have
felt that toward the end.
Now if you didn't feel it, you
probably took a catch breath.
So try to avoid doing that.
If you really didn't
take a catch breath
and you still
didn't feel it, you
weren't talking loud
enough, because I
have a really strong diaphragm.
I can feel this any time I
want to just by getting louder.
So you can get louder.
But you could also
make it longer.
You could do the months of the
year, or count from 1 to 30.
You can definitely can
make this exercise work.
Most people do not like that
feeling of the diaphragm
being so connected.
And so we end up with
this kind of pattern--
the beginning of the
sentence is nice and strong
because there's plenty of air.
But as soon as the
diaphragm begins to squeeze,
the person just
relaxes the diaphragm
and keeps talking anyway to
the end of their sentence.
Next sentence, plenty of air at
the beginning of the sentence,
but then they just
relax that diaphragm,
sometimes trail off down
here for a very long time
before they reach the
end of that sentence.
So you have to either breathe
more often, which is fine,
or develop more stamina.
So basically stick the landing.
Make sure you always speak to
the ends of your sentences.
The diaphragm is
responsible for volume.
Most people grip in
their larynx when
they increase their volume.
But this area right here
plays very, very little role
in volume.
All of your effort should
come from this down here.
So to practice this, we're
going to count from 1 to 5.
And I want you to get
incrementally louder.
So when you say one, it's as
if you were speaking to someone
two feet in front of you.
And by the time
you say five, you
are talking to
someone 30 feet away.
I will demonstrate first.
One, two, three, four, five.
So you hear I got
incrementally louder?
All right, let's try that scale.
I should hear a huge difference
between one and five.
Here we go.
AUDIENCE: One two,
three, four, five.
CARA HALE ALTER: All
right, pretty good.
So I heard an increase
in volume, for sure.
I also heard an
increase in pitch.
Now when your pitch goes
up with your volume,
that's what yelling sounds like.
So right this very second
when I'm talking to you,
my volume is not
hurting your ears,
but my pitch would
drive you crazy,
because I'm yelling at you.
So when you say five, you
can't say (HIGH PITCHED) five.
You have to say
(NORMAL PITCH) five.
All right, so let's
try that again.
This time, don't let your
pitch go up as you're speaking.
Nice and easy on one.
ALL TOGETHER: One,
two, three, four, five.
CARA HALE ALTER: Exactly, that's
where your voice lives-- five--
right there.
That's where the power is.
That's where the resonance is.
Try to keep this
area very relaxed.
All right, so there
we have voice.
Eye contact-- in human
communication, eye contact
is vital.
In Western business, eye contact
may be the number one indicator
of trustworthiness.
Have you heard the phrase,
"Can you look me in the eye
and say that?"
So to Westerners
especially, it's
not just making eye contact.
It's holding eye contact.
It's the duration
of the eye contact.
And across the globe,
there's a wide range
of what is appropriate
from culture to culture.
So you should be very sensitive
to the areas you find yourself
in.
But in the Western
world especially,
three to five seconds per
person is comfortable.
So let me give you my
scale from one to five.
You can see what
this looks like.
One on the scale, I'm
not looking at anybody.
I'm sure you've seen
plenty of speakers
where he or she just simply
doesn't look at the people
he or she is talking to.
So this is off the scale
in the wrong direction.
This would be a one.
Level two eye contact is a
scanning sort of eye contact.
And in some schools
of thought, this
would be considered good,
because my eyes are up
instead of on the floor.
But in my book, this
isn't good enough.
I'm not really
seeing you out there.
My eyes just happen to
be glancing across yours.
So this is level
two-- below average.
Level three eye contact is
about a second or so per person.
And so what I'm
doing now is fine.
There's nothing wrong with
this level of eye contact.
It's just that I'm missing
so many opportunities
with this level.
Level four eye contact,
hopefully, I've
been doing all along.
I really see you over there.
You know that I see you.
We are having a
conversation for a moment.
So this is much more organic,
so much more connected, so
much more like
one-on-one communication.
And I know you can't
count in your head,
because of course,
your brain is busy.
But the technique is
to look at someone
until you get to the comma
or the pause in the phrase.
And then you turn and
look at somebody else
until you get to comma
or pause in that phrase.
And then you look
at somebody else.
So you're using your
sentence structure
as a way of moving
from person to person.
That also keeps it very organic.
There are so many great reasons
to make strong eye contact.
One, there is research that
shows the person of highest
rank or position
in the conversation
holds eye contact longer
when they are speaking,
and shorter when
they're listening.
And the opposite
is true of someone
who has a lower rank or status
in the conversation-- they hold
eye contact longer when
listening, and shorter when
they personally are speaking.
Now I think it's a good idea
to hold eye contact both
when you are listening and
when you were speaking.
But don't accidentally
lower your status.
Because as a listener, you've
been making great eye contact.
And as soon as your
mouth begins to move,
you cannot keep the connection.
So you need to at least
balance that out so
that you can have both
sides of the equation.
Especially because I
work with a lot of people
who are very technically
minded, sometimes someone
will say to me, Cara, I
just don't feel comfortable
making eye contact.
It makes me uncomfortable.
And I get that.
I completely get it, in that
it's such a common issue
that I definitely understand.
But I put it in the category
of someone who might say to me,
you know, I just don't feel
comfortable with computers.
I mean, I've tried.
I'm uncomfortable
with technology.
That's true-- extremely
common out there,
that people are
uncomfortable with that.
It's just that in
both cases, you
might have to just get
past that learning curve.
Because if you don't want,
it might hold you back
from reaching your full
potential in the business
world.
All right, one way you
can practice your eye
contact-- and this
really, really
works-- take some Post-It
notes, put them up
on the walls around you or
the chairs in front of you,
talk about something--
maybe some information
you have to deliver-- and
look at this Post-It note.
Then when you get to the
comma or pause in that phrase,
look at this Post-It note.
When you get to the comma
or pause in that phrase,
look at this Post-It note.
Because part of
learning eye contact
is just learning the rhythm
and the choreography of what
it's like to keep
your eyes focused
and think at the same time.
And so while of course we want
the human connection-- that
is absolutely a vital
part of eye contact--
really seeing people on the
other side-- at least early on,
there's truly a skill set of
being able to think and keep
your eyes up at the same time.
And that's one way
to practice that.
All right, so there we have it--
strong posture, strong voice,
and strong eye contact.
So far, everything I've
been talking about,
these are things you should do.
And you really should.
You're going to look great
if you do these things.
But now let's take a
look at some things
you shouldn't do-- things
that can undercut your image.
The number one derailer
out there-- filler words--
you know, kind of, sort of,
actually, basically, I mean,
right, OK-- of
course, uh's and um's.
This behavior is often invisible
to the speaker, and quite often
invisible to the listener,
until the listener notices.
And then it's like a big,
red flag that goes off.
Have you ever had
that happen to you,
where you catch on
to someone's filler
and you start keeping
a little tally?
I had a woman in one of
my workshops recently,
and there were eight
people in that workshop.
In her introduction, which
lasted about a minute--
she introduced yourself--
she said "you know" 15 times.
When I was giving
her feedback, I said,
are you aware that you
said "you know" a lot?
And she wasn't aware she'd
even said it one time.
What was most interesting
is I turned to the rest
of the group.
And as I said, eight
people in the room.
I said, did any of you notice?
Only two out of
eight had noticed.
So it was invisible to
her, and it was also
invisible to most of them.
This is what we call
selective attention.
And think goodness for
selective attention,
or we wouldn't be able to have
a conversation with a friend
in a crowded restaurant.
We are really good
at tuning into just
the stream of
information we want,
and ignoring everything else.
So this is a talent that we
all carry around with us.
So it's true that most of
us have selective attention.
We are trying to
listen to the message
that somebody else is
saying, and we're not
noticing the filler words.
But once someone catches
on to your filler words,
oh, game over.
That's all they can
pay attention to
for a period of time.
And even if they're not noticing
the actual fillers, what
they are noticing
is a quality of not
being concise, or focused,
or as direct as you
might want to come across.
So you just don't want to give
them the ammunition out there.
The solution for eliminating
the fillers is to pause.
Leave that white space there,
just that anti-pause there.
And that is absolutely
easier said than done,
because most people develop
the problem because they're
uncomfortable pausing.
So you have to go back and
learn that particular skill.
I have a game that
we do in class,
and we don't have time today
for us to do this right now,
but I'll teach it to you.
And then I hope
sometime today you
will do it with someone else.
So you sit across from a
partner, and each of you
will talk for 90
seconds on a topic.
And it might be
something like places
in the world you'd
like to visit--
so something you can easily
talk about for 90 seconds.
And your goal is to
eliminate the uh's
and um's from the conversation
while you're talking.
So you have your own
turn for 90 seconds.
The listener flags
like this any uh or um
he or she hears-- hand
up and back down again.
So you can catch
them in the moment.
As the listener, if
you're playing this game
as the listener-- I
would never give you
this advice in any
other situation--
but don't really listen to them.
Just listen for uh's and um's.
Because you've been trained
your entire life to ignore them.
And now I want
you to catch them.
And it's actually quite
hard to catch them,
because you do get caught
up in what they have to say.
So just like a social
scientist, pay attention
to the words that are
coming out of their mouths,
and see if you can catch
those filler words.
And to help you out
with this-- so I
want you to play that
game with someone-- so
90 seconds each on the topic.
Flag like this.
You might be amazed
how difficult it
is to pull them out, even when
you are thinking about it.
With everything I've
talked about today,
there is a learning curve.
And some are longer or
shorter than others.
But of everything
I've talked about,
eliminating the fillers
is the longest learning
curve-- takes longest time to
get them out of your style.
But if you were to play
this game, this flag game,
for three minutes
a day for 20 days,
the problem would be
gone-- absolutely gone.
And most people
don't follow through
and play a game for 20 times.
But if you were to play it for
20 times over the next 20 days,
the problem would be gone.
The reason why you
only have to focus
for three minutes on the
skill and it'll be gone
is that the rest of
the day, your brain
won't be able to stop
thinking about it.
And so you only have
to force yourself
to do the three minutes.
And the problem will,
in fact, be gone.
So I have a tool that
I'd like to give you.
And it's called my
flag game checklist.
And it's 20 impromptu questions,
so you can play this game.
It's got little check
marks next to it,
so you have to check it off
and prove to yourself that you
actually followed through
with this particular exercise.
And I'm going to post
on my website for you.
I didn't know exactly what
I was going to cover today.
This was going to be
a little bit fluid.
But I did set up a page so if
I ever mentioned a resource,
I could post it there for you.
And that is SpeechSkills--
that's my company-
SpeechSkills.com/googletalks.
So if you want this checklist,
you can get it free.
Just go to that page, and you
can download the checklist.
And I can guarantee you,
if you play for 20 days,
the problem will be gone.
So those are the fillers.
The next few derailer
that I want to talk about
is this misplaced
upward inflection.
So a downward inflection is when
your pitch cascades downward
at the ends of your
phrases and sentences.
The upward inflection can be
as bad as this Valley Girl type
thing, where I have a question
word at the end of my sentence.
It doesn't have to be this bad.
But if my voice just keeps
going up into these upper tones,
and I don't come back
down into my lower times,
I'm not going to sound
as committed or as mature
as I might want to come across.
So the downward inflection
when speaking in English
is the traditional, or rather
unmarked, dialect of English,
where we start high
and we end low.
It's the function
of a statement.
The upward inflection is
the function of a question,
and it starts low and ends high.
So let me just demonstrate the
down inflection starts high.
The other day, I went to
the Golden Gate Bridge.
And while I was there, I watched
the sailboats in the water.
So that's just classic,
unmarked dialect in English.
The upward inflection
does the exact opposite--
starts low, ends high.
The other day, I went to
the Golden Gate Bridge.
And while I was there, I watched
the sailboats in the water.
So if you want to
change the behavior,
you can't just change
the end of the sentence.
You have to change the
beginning of the sentence.
You need to start high and low.
My daughter, when she
was in high school,
she and all of her friends
spoke in near-constant upward
inflections.
And so did her
teachers, by the way,
when I would go to
parent-teacher conferences.
This is the arena she
lived in every single day.
Well, I didn't want to ostracize
her from her peer group.
And it was fine when she was
speaking with their peers
to have that particular
style-- no problem.
But every now and then when
she would be talking to me,
I would say, can you
turn around for me?
Can you just put that
in a downward function?
And so, of course she
would roll her eyes,
but then she would do it.
But pretty soon, she became very
much like being multilingual.
She could use upward inflections
or downward inflections.
They were easy
for her to adjust.
Well, this gives her a
significant advantage
over her peer group.
Because when she goes
for a job interview,
and the person in front
of her being interviewed
is saying something
like, I honestly
believe that I can be the
go-to person for this position?
And if you just
give me the chance,
I know that I can
get the job done?
My daughter will be
saying, I honestly
believe that I can be the
go-to person for this position.
And if you just
give me the chance,
I know I can get the job done.
And the interviewer
won't know why
she sounds more committed,
more mature, more intelligent
than the person he just
interviewed, but she will.
So she has this advantage.
And you can also
have this advantage.
The downward inflection
is never a penalty.
It's an unmarked version
of speaking in English.
And there can, in
fact, be a penalty
for using the upward inflection.
So I'm just encouraging you
to gain control over that.
In your particular demographic,
that upward inflection
is very, very common.
All right, so those
are the derailers.
There are a lot of
derailers, but those
are the two most common.
So now this balance between
authority and approachability--
the great news is I have
covered all of this information.
I'm just going to put it into
a slightly different context
for you.
If you'd like to appear
more authoritative,
take up space, maintain
direct eye contact,
keep your head level,
try to be still,
use strong volume and resonance,
and downward inflections.
That would bolster up
the authoritative side.
If you'd like to come
across as more approachable,
what can you do?
Well, you can take
up less space,
but let me just put a
caution on this one.
The reason this one makes my
list, taking up less space,
is that there just are some
people who come on too strong.
And the very first
thing they need
to do to be more approachable is
to take up a little less space.
Unless you get that
feedback on a regular basis,
that's not the best place
to find approachability.
Better places to find
approachability-- fluid,
interactive gestures, fluid,
interactive facial gestures,
lots of expression
in your voice,
and then ability to
elicit a response,
to engage with the
person on the other side.
Now I'm trying to do both of
those lists at the same time.
With the exception of taking
up more or less space, which
I can fluidly move
between, I am trying
to do both of those lists.
I'm hoping, I'm
hoping you would find
it difficult to decide if I
am more authoritative or more
approachable on this topic.
But depending on
the situation, I
can absolutely lean one
direction or the other,
depending on what's needed
in the communication.
The problem exists when you're
trying for one attribute,
but you're using a negative
behavior to get there.
So these are not the
only ways to create
authority and approachability.
You could create authority
by having a poker face, being
monotone, emphatic gestures.
But those are pretty
negative behaviors,
and they would completely
undercut your approachability,
so I don't recommend them.
You can create more
approachability by bobbing
your head a lot when you
speak, have excessive smiling,
and use that upward inflection.
But that would undercut
your authority.
So I don't recommend
that, either.
The behaviors on these two
lists are actually safe.
You build that
behavior, you're not
likely to get any kind of
push back because of it.
They are positive
ways to develop
authority and approachability.
All right, if you were
thinking in your head,
I do not know how I'm going to
think about all these things
and talk at the same time,
of course I get that.
There's no way you can think
about all of these things
and talk at the same time.
It is conceivable you can think
about one of these behaviors
and talk at the same time.
That's how you practice,
as a matter of fact.
All of these behaviors have
to be in your muscle memory,
in your habits,
your subroutines.
Subroutines are all those
channels of communication that
are happening simultaneously.
There is no way you can think
about them all actively,
but they are happening
simultaneously.
And in every
category of behavior
that I've talked about here, you
already have these subroutines.
These behaviors are already
in your subroutines.
It's just that you
may not have the best
behavior in your subroutine.
So you might have to
go back and rewrite
that, practice a little bit,
develop that new subroutine.
Once you develop
a subroutine, it
is effortless to
perform that skill.
It takes no brain
space whatsoever.
It's kind of like riding a bike.
Do you find it difficult
to ride a bike?
Depends on whether
you ever learned,
because once you've
learned to ride a bike,
once that's a
competent subroutine,
it takes hardly any
effort at all to do it.
Now learning to
ride a bike, that
is a whole different thing.
That is actually difficult,
takes a lot of mental energy,
as a matter of fact,
mental attention
to learn to ride a bike.
But once you know how to ride
a bike, you could ride a bike
and write a poem
at the same time,
or do a complicated
math problem,
or have a conversation with
the person next to you.
So you could do a lot of
upper-level mental processing
and still be able
to ride a bike.
But if you were trying
to learn to ride a bike,
you wouldn't be able to
do any of those things.
And so that's what it's like
to develop these skills.
You have to put in
the practice time
so that you can develop
that subroutine.
Once you develop the subroutine,
actually it is effortless.
And it doesn't take
any mental energy.
You own the behavior.
There are three reasons
people don't typically
take on these skills.
And one is that there's a belief
that these skills are actually
talents.
Some people have more talent
in this area than others.
And hopefully, I've
dispelled some of those myths
today-- that these are
actually behaviors.
And any one of these
behaviors you can do.
If you discover that your
chin is low like this,
it does not take talent
to get your head level.
And so does it take
talent to ride a bike?
No, it takes practice.
And certainly some people
are going to learn quicker
than others, so that's where the
talent component might come in.
But once you learn,
it's the same skill.
Doesn't matter
who learned first.
You still have the same skills.
So hopefully, you'll
see these as talents.
Now sometimes people don't
know what to practice.
And hopefully, I've helped
with some of that today, too.
And you'll find more
information in "The Credibility
Code," the book itself,
or in my online course.
So today's conversation, I
have tried to be concise.
I call this "The Credibility
Code in a Nutshell."
But we can take a much
more comprehensive look
at this information
if you're interested.
And if you go, by the way, to my
SpeechSkills/googletalks page,
you can get some information
about my online course.
And in that course, my intention
is to be comprehensive,
to really thoroughly answer
this question, complete with how
do you self-assess, and skill
drills, and practice ideas,
so you can truly learn to embody
these particular behaviors?
But the second
reason people don't
tend to master these
skills is that--
and this is a tough
pill to swallow--
but we are blind to
our own inefficiencies.
And that makes perfect sense.
If we are being ineffective,
it is almost certainly
unintentional, because nobody
is ineffective on purpose.
And so we are either blind to
the behavior that is going on,
or we are blind to the impact
that behavior may be having.
And we're back to subroutines.
Once something
becomes a subroutine,
it takes no mental
energy whatsoever.
So we don't even
know we're doing it.
I have to say, the
number one thing I
hear when people watch
their videos is, wow,
I had no idea I was doing
whatever that thing might be.
So it's very, very helpful.
Be brave.
Take a look at yourself
from the outside.
And of course, it's helpful
to get feedback from a coach.
But don't underestimate the
power of doing it on your own.
Set up a video camera in your
office or in your living room,
and just get a look
at yourself and see
what might be coming across.
And the third reason people
don't take on these skills
is that you just severely
overestimate how much time it
takes to take them on.
As I mentioned, with
the hardest behavior
we're dealing with today--
eliminating the fillers-- three
minutes a day for 20 days
would solve the problem.
In my online course--
it's a six-week course,
and I only require 10
minutes a day of practice
to master all of the skills
we've been talking about.
So people severely overestimate
how much time it will take.
But I will say this--
the reason it only
takes 10 minutes
of practice a day
is that your brain
won't be able to stop
thinking about it for
the rest of the day.
So you only have to
commit to the 10 minutes,
and then the rest will
take care of itself.
All right, I'll take any
questions you might have.
If there's something
pressing on your mind,
you've been dying to ask
a particular question.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
wondering if you thought
of any of these skills
through the filter of that
being a part of your day.
This also applies
to teleconferencing.
CARA HALE ALTER:
OK, so first of all,
if you find video
conferencing weird,
it's because it's weird in that
it's amazing how finely attuned
we are so the subtle signals
we read in other people
and also timing.
That if you ask
somebody a question,
if a split extra second goes by
before they answer, we wonder,
was there something wrong?
Are you feeling
weird about that?
So we're very, very attuned to
timing and physical signals.
And that's really messed up
on the video conferencing.
And so you first of all just
have to have room for that.
And then verbally, be
as explicit as you can
when you're talking to
people on the other side.
So often it will
happen in meetings
that I have that heads
will nod around the table,
but the people on the other side
are not necessarily hearing,
noting, the head nods.
So try to be as
explicit about what
you might be seeing
in the room if you're
the facilitator-- oh, it
looks like everybody here
agrees with that,
or we have a lot--
something along that line.
And just leave extra room.
Also, one of the
things I find funniest
about video
conferencing is watching
people who are not speaking.
So because you're
basically on camera,
you might have to be a little
more attentive to the fact
that you are being watched, even
if you're not the one talking.
And recognize that
you still need
to project a confident image
even in listening mode.
We haven't had a chance to
talk about listening skills,
but they are vital as well.
So in this short conversation,
hard for me to go deep in that.
But I would say, just
recognize it is strange.
And verbally try
to hold up your end
of the non-verbals that would be
going on in the communication.
Any other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So when it
comes to speaking,
how does it work for the
non-native English speakers
and non-native speakers,
and accent, voice,
lots of differences of that.
So do you have any--
CARA HALE ALTER:
Absolutely, I've
got something to say about that.
So what's interesting about
accents-- so first of all,
we all have accents.
We just have different ones.
And our brains are
wired for novelty.
So if you have an accent that's
different than the people
you are speaking
to, you're already
going to have more
of their attention.
So an accent can be
a huge advantage.
Also, let me say this--
do you like listening
to accents, people who have an
accent different than your own?
Almost everyone says yes.
We like listening to accents.
So we don't want
to get rid of them.
Almost always when someone
has an accent problem,
that's not really
what's going on.
It's usually some other element.
They have an
articulation problem.
So our brains, when we
hear an accent that's
different than our
own, immediately
recognize the substitutions,
because there are
rules that you're following.
It's not just willy-nilly.
You are substituting a
certain vowel or a consonant.
Our brains will
catch on, and then
be able to make those
substitutions-- unless we
can't hear them.
So sometimes, it's articulation.
The person, maybe
because they're
shy that they have an
accent, will kind of
slide by the consonant so
they don't make mistakes,
or they're not blasting the
difference in their accent
out there.
Same thing with
volume-- people who
are speaking in an accent
or a language that's
not their [? second ?]
language will
often pull back in
volume because they don't
want to make loud mistakes.
They'd rather make
soft mistakes,
which means that the other
people can't hear you
very well.
And that's the
communication problem.
And then amazingly,
sometimes it's pace.
I can't tell you
how often it happens
when someone is speaking English
to me as their second language,
that they talk too fast for me.
And I don't know if this is
over-compensation for maybe
wanting to show that
fluidity with language.
But often, pace is the issue.
It's hard for me to keep up.
So I would say rather
than changing your accent,
accent could be a
positive for you.
But do make sure that your
volume, your articulation,
and your pacing is clear
and appropriate at optimal.
That's how you handle an
accent problem-- "problem"--
not really a problem.
Great, if there's another
pressing question out there,
yes.
AUDIENCE: What's the
appropriate posture
when you're on stage presenting
but not necessarily speaking?
CARA HALE ALTER: This
happens to me all the time.
So you are in waiting mode.
And so I-- first of all, there's
a difference between listing
posture and speaking posture.
So everything I've
been doing, I've
been demonstrating
speaking posture.
But when you're listening,
it's like the difference
between being the pitcher
and being the catcher.
And so if you're sitting
and listening, actually
rounding out a little
bit, it looks like you're
absorbing the message better.
If I sat stock still
and listened to you,
you might not think I
was being very attentive.
So the same thing
is true up here.
If you ask me a question,
and I sit here like this
and listen to you, that might
not seem very receptive.
So I have a tendency to
go into listening mode
where I round out
just a little bit.
If you were to talk for
over a long period of time,
I might even take my
weight to my side.
But I will say this-- my
spine is always straight.
So you still want to have the
core straight through here.
And it's nice to find
a listening posture
for yourself-- it can look
different on you than on me--
that you feel comfortable in.
And then use it as
your go-to position
if you ever become
uncomfortable.
I was giving a talk at
the Bar Association,
so just about 200
lawyers in the room.
And one man took issue
with what I was saying,
and all of a sudden began to
do this while I was talking.
[LAUGHTER]
So when I asked for
questions, his hand popped up.
Great.
So I asked him, questions.
He stood up, and then he went on
for a couple of minutes railing
on me for something.
He had misunderstood
something I said.
We did clear it up.
But so I had to follow
my own guidelines there.
And I had to continually
give myself instructions
to look comfortable.
So I had to do things like,
OK, try to stay still,
round out, take a
couple of steps.
Stand still, nod.
So I was trying to get myself
to look perfectly comfortable,
even though inside, my
brain was going augh.
So you find something that
looks comfortable on your body.
This is really
comfortable for me.
So if I'm just waiting,
if somebody else
is talking on stage, I
usually would stand like this,
or I might possibly take
my weight over to one side
while I'm waiting.
And of course, you have to
be attentive to your partners
on stage.
You can't zone out,
because if you have
to use active listening skills.
Good to cheat out
to the audience,
so that you look like
you're including them
in the conversation.
And so, did that
answer your question?
All right, good, because
it looks like we have, yes,
one other one.
AUDIENCE: So my question
is that if you suddenly
lose your train of
thought, then how
do you compensate
that and still be
seen as like you're confident?
CARA HALE ALTER:
Yes, so first of all,
it's important to note that
thinking on your feet--
so I put that as a category--
thinking on your feet
is a skill.
And most people hate feeling
flustered and uncomfortable
so much that we avoid
it any time we can,
which means you only have to
go through that when it really
matters.
So I encourage you
to play games where
you have to be in that
thinking on your feet mode,
where you have to come up
with answers really quickly.
Just so you, if
you want to know,
I came up with a boxed
set of impromptus
just for this purpose.
So I can give them to my
clients so you can always
have some sort of fresh
question you have to take up
the top of your head.
So thinking on your
feet is a skill.
And one of the
problems that happens
when we're thinking
on our feet is
there's a lot of self
criticism if we go blank.
So you go blank, and then
all of a sudden, your brain
starts to say things
like, oh, my gosh,
now I've lost my
train of thought.
Oh, everybody's waiting for me.
Oh, gosh darn this.
I wish I wasn't in this mode.
You've got that screaming
going on in your head.
It is really hard to think when
that's happening in your head.
So one of the things you learn
in the thinking on your feet
exercises is just to put
that conversation aside.
Go find the information
that you need.
But when you're
panicking about the fact
that you've gone blank, your
head is busy talking about that
rather than finding the content.
So that's the first thing
I would suggest-- get
good at that particular skill.
And then note that you have so
much more time than you think.
Your listener will wait if
you find the information.
I suggest that you not
apologize for yourself.
So that's really important.
If you have lost your train
of thought, try not to say,
oh, gosh-- like, beat yourself
up in front of your audience.
You simply say
something like, huh,
that thought was just there a
second ago, and now it's gone.
Give me a second.
All right, well, so it's
OK to take some time.
And/or, you can say, I've
lost my train of thought.
I'm sure it'll come back to me.
Let me move forward.
But you say it with
confidence, so it
doesn't look like you
are yelling at yourself,
so you aren't, in fact, yelling
at yourself inside your head.
One of the derailers
I didn't bring up
is what we call self-commenting.
And it is a pretty
prevalent derailer.
And so self-commenting
is when you
comment on or apologize
for some perceived mistake
that you make.
And so I'm going to make a
mistake on purpose so you
can hear me apologize for it.
Let's just say that
I'm talking along,
and I mispronunce-- I'm
sorry-- mispronounce something,
and make a big show out
of it, like I just did.
I tripped over that word.
I laughed at myself.
I said I was sorry.
I did a little, cute dance.
And then I moved forward.
[LAUGHTER]
So that pointed
fingers at the mistake.
That was a pretty
obvious self-comment.
Here's a much more
subtle self-comment.
Let's just say that
I'm talking along.
And I mis-, mis-, mispronounce
something and then keep going--
so just a little flinch or
scold of myself before I move
forward.
We make those kinds of errors
where we mispronounce something
and correct it or use
incorrect grammar and fix it--
we do this so often.
The metric on this is that
it happens once or twice
per paragraph in
everyday communication.
We trip over a word,
fix it, and move on.
I have done it
numerous times up here.
Have you noticed?
Typically, we just
correct and move on.
It's seamless.
It is a seamless subroutine.
Here's how it'd sound.
Let's just say that
I'm talking along.
And I mi-, mispronounce
something and then keep going.
No reaction whatsoever, but when
we are feeling self-conscious
we notice every
mistake that we make.
We react.
That's what chips away
at your credibility.
So you do have to correct
a mistake if you make one.
You just shouldn't
apologize for it in any way.
Correct and move on.
Never let them see your
internal conversation
about how you are doing.
I am going to wrap up this
conversation with just
a one-minute story.
This is a true story,
happened in my life.
When my kids were little,
I played with them
in the morning, and then
took them off to preschool.
And that particular day,
as I ran my errands,
and I went to the bank,
and to the grocery store,
and to the dry cleaner,
everywhere I went,
people greeted me with
these big, beaming smiles.
It's like the whole, entire
world is in a fantastic
mood, like fairy dust had
sprinkled on the earth
and they were in a
fantastic mood out there.
And then I got home, and I
caught a glimpse of myself
in the mirror.
And I had forgotten that when
I was playing with the kids,
I had drawn a kitty nose
and whiskers on my face.
[LAUGHTER]
So all day long, everywhere
I went, I had this kitty nose
and whiskers.
Now, nobody had
mentioned it-- nobody.
Now why do you think
they didn't mention it?
AUDIENCE: They assumed
you intended to do that.
CARA HALE ALTER: Exactly,
they assumed I knew.
So obvious a signal could
not have been accidental
on my part.
So this leads us to a very
important lesson about
today's conversation, and
that is you cannot assume
you're going to get
outside feedback.
You have to seek out outside
feedback on your skills.
Because people assume you know.
And if you don't know,
they don't necessarily
want to be the one to tell
you if you are blind to it.
But I encourage you
to get an outside look
at yourself, and
especially on video camera,
so you can see what
you might need to fix.
The reason people make
such amazing progress
in such a short
period of time is
that this is not about ability.
It's about awareness.
That when you know you
need to change a behavior,
it's actually fairly easy
to change the behavior.
It's the awareness
that is the component
that you need to work on.
So I encourage you, by all
means, when you leave here
today, try to get
some outside feedback.
You can ask others, but your
best bet is video camera,
even if it's your own iPhone.
All right, thank you for
being here, everybody.
I enjoyed my time.
[APPLAUSE]